[Musique]
chez les shadoks c'est la panique
leur planète est en train de changer de
forme comme nos téléspectateurs le
savent la planète shadow qui était
soutenu dans l'espace par des shadoks
spéciaux avec des pâtes en eau et qui
empêchaient la planète de tomber mais
c'est shadoks là n'avait aucun sens de
leur responsabilité et il arrivait même
à certains d'aller se coucher
de sorte que quand il était sur le dos
leurs pattes ne soutenait plus rien du
tout et la planète aussitôt se déformer
ou bien pour protester ils se mettaient
tous du même côté et la planète devenait
alors pratiquement inutilisable
quand je de couler en vélo
sur une route par exemple la route
pouvait tout à coup de devenir un
escalier ou n'importe quoi
et c'était obligé d'avoir des vélos
spéciaux avec des roues de formes
diverses pour faire face à toute
éventualité
[Musique]
de même quand il monte un escalier il
n'était jamais sûr d'arriver en haut ils
ne savaient plus quelle était des
escaliers qui montent et et ceux qui
descendait et sauf qu'on s'étaient
expressément écrit dessus
alors il arrivait souvent qu'avec un
escalier prévu pour la montée on
réussisse à monter plus bas qu'on ne
serait descendu avec un escalier prévu
pour la descente dans ces conditions la
logique shadok ne reposait pas sur des
bases solides ce qui nuisait
considérablement au développement normal
de leur intelligence et spécialement en
matière de fusées interplanétaire
[Musique]